hey everyone what's happening I was
thinking the other day and I realized
that while my day in the life video is
cool and chill and all it doesn't really
do a great job of explaining what
exactly I do at my job and I figured
that's probably something you all want
to know so today I'm going to talk in
detail about what I do at work okay
let's begin throughout my career I've
been mostly focused on writing mobile
apps and to be specific when I mean
mobile apps
I mean apps that tend to be more
productivity or social focused these are
some of the apps that I worked on I'm
what some people call a product engineer
since the engineering that I do is
directly related to the product that
people use some engineers are not
product engineers by contrast and they
work to provide services for other
software engineers or make improvements
to websites and apps that they run
faster and so that they're up and
running all the time
so in order to talk a little bit about
my responsibilities as a product
engineer let's type in and talk a little
bit about the product process we have a
product manager or PM who kicks off this
whole process by deciding on what we're
building it then gets handed over to a
designer who figures out how is this
thing gonna look and then finally it
gets handed over to the engineer who
builds something so let's walk through a
simple example so say that you and I are
working on an app for food delivery the
product manager might say hey let's put
a button on the home screen so that
users can order their favorite dish from
their favorite restaurant on one tap the
designer would then take it and then
figure out how it's going to look on the
screen by creating mock-ups the mock-ups
link I hit it over to the engineer who
implements and shifts the feature to its
users the whole process is actually very
collaborative and he's usually not
divided up like how I described as an
assembly-line
what actually happens is that we all
provide our own expertise but then we
end up making a lot of decisions
together and so I would say a solid 20
percent of my time is spent doing
exactly this I should also mention that
this process moves super quickly it's
not uncommon for us to conceive an idea
and get it out within a week or two
because there are several people
involved in this process to keep
everyone in the loop you have frequent
meetings in order to communicate what
we're all working on ok so 20% of my
time is spent working
pm's designers and other engineers to
discuss what we're working on next 70%
of my time is spent building stuff so
based on the discussions we've had with
the product manager and designer it's up
to me and the other engineers to build
the thing my process usually goes
something like this
number one figure out a plan for how to
build the thing I asked myself questions
like do I need to coordinate with other
teams of my company in order to
accomplish this what classes am I gonna
make should I use what Apple's provided
me or should I make my own custom
version of it how am I going to format
the data that I want to show in the way
that I want and once I have a plan
sometimes I'll review with other
engineers to make sure that my plan
makes sense so lastly I go and code
according to my plan and sometimes it
goes according to plan and sometimes it
doesn't but it certainly helps to have a
plan so that it saves time and
frustration in addition to building
features I will be fixing bugs in the
meantime or making improvements to
retest and tooling to make development
easier so this whole portion of reading
writing and fixing code takes quite a
bit of time because of all the little
problems I'm solving along the way and
so usually a large portion of my day is
spent doing this and so the last 10% of
my day is spent doing miscellaneous
things things like having one-on-ones
with my manager and other people to talk
about career stuff participating in
meetings in other parts of the company
to find out what everyone is working on
and just kind of working and
participating in any other areas that I
am passionate about at work okay so if
my math is correct that comes out to a
hundred percent 20% collaborating with
cross-functional roles
70% building and coding and 10%
miscellaneous things around the company
and not every day looks the same on the
job there are some days where I have
meetings all day and I code only for an
hour so and there are other days where I
have no leadings and I code for the
whole day the variety of my days helped
me to maintain a good balance anyways I
hope that gives a little more clarity
into what I do at work thank you so much
for watching don't forget to subscribe
to my channel for new videos and if you
like this video give it a thumbs up and
leave a comment down below
if you have any questions or if you'd
like to tell us what your workday looks
like see you next time and hope you have
a great day talking about terrace house
with my coworkers going on coffee breaks
showing people pictures of my cat and
dog
[Music]